turkey is an economic turmoil people are
queueing for bread cutting back on meat
and are even fleeing to other countries
why
inflation which currently stands at more
than 21 according to government
statistics the u.s inflation rate by
comparison is at a 39-year high of 6.8
nearly twice as much as a global average
of 3.5 percent
unlike the us turkey is an emerging
market it seemed two decades of broad
economic growth and an expanding middle
class but now the lira is in free fall
as the country reckons with president
rajab tayyip erdogan's unorthodox
economic approach which is contrary to
widely accepted inflationary wisdom
as central banks around the world
respond to a stronger than expected
pickup in inflation amid economic
recovery from the pandemic there are
lessons to be learned from turkey's
approach
in a nutshell to prevent the economy
from overheating central banks can
increase the cost of borrowing by
raising interest rates which curbs the
rate of inflation and this is precisely
what is happening in most other emerging
market central banks to great effect but
turkey central bank has done the
opposite under pressure from president
erdogan who has invoked a religious
prohibition on usury in his argument
against high interest rates the rate has
been cut three times since mid-september
which is torpedoed the value of the lira
a rapidly weakened currency pushes up
the cost of key imports like food and
energy this is already hurting the
turkish people's bank accounts
of the turkish public said the
government was handling the economy
badly
the crisis has prompted protests mostly
from union members and calls for
erdogan's government to resign
turkish banks so far have been able to
withstand the currency crisis
but economists are concerned that a
further collapse of the lyra could
trigger a bank run or that turkey could
default on its foreign debts erdogan
meanwhile has said he welcomes the
depreciation of the lira to encourage an
export-based economy similar to japan
and taiwan he and other officials have
insisted that the currency fluctuations
are temporary some economists have said
that the strategy is likely to fail
because inflation has put pressure on
exporters who now have to pay more for
energy and raw materials others doubt
that turkey's inflation is even at 21.3
percent an independent research group
estimates that in reality the figure is
more than 58
investors and economists fear that
turkey's embattled economy could get
worse before it gets better